hi there steve kaufman today i want to
talk about why kids learn
languages better than adults
now i know i have said in the past
that adults can learn better than kids
and this is true to the extent that
adults have more life experience have a
a larger vocabulary in their own
language
which can help them to acquire more
vocabulary in a new language so that you
know in
less than a year in czech i can read
serious books on history
in czech that a child of seven wouldn't
read
however when it comes to producing the
language understanding the language
based on
sort of the the
content based on what they're hearing
around them
uh the children do better they speak
better they speak with less of an accent
they understand better they speak more
naturally by and large they are better
in most cases now this assumes that the
child is interested
we all know of school children who for
example here in canada take french for
10 or 12 years and at the end of it they
can't speak french because they're not
interested so uh putting kids who aren't
very interested in a formal classroom is
not going to enable them to learn
however if you sent that same child who
couldn't learn in a classroom if you
sent them off to a french speaking
environment within six months they'd be
speaking fairly fluently whereas their
parents would not be
and why is that well the reason i'm sort
of making this a little video is because
i was reminded of how well kids learn
with the example of my grandson now my
grandson is very interested in playing
hockey
uh not surprising because his father
played hockey and of course i played not
very well
and he's not so interested in golf but a
friend of his
two years ago decided to uh join the
junior program at our golf club so now
after two years
this friend of my grandsons is a good
golfer shoots in the 80s has a natural
swing looks really good
my grandson hasn't really progressed in
the two years
but
i thought about the fact that at the
golf club all the kids in the junior
program they've all got these natural
swings they look good they seem to play
golf well
within a couple of years they're able to
play and then i think of the adults like
myself and others who over the last 10
years
despite
working out on the driving range and
taking lessons they essentially don't
improve
uh very much and many of them actually
go downhill
why is that why can the kids just within
a year or two just get up there
naturally they're swinging the ball and
they're mostly they're fooling around
and having fun while they're learning
and yet they seem to improve and the
adults who are so intent and they're
they read the golf magazines on what to
do with their elbow their knee their
shoulder
this and that and they don't seem to
improve very much
and
it's not it don't i mean that the kids
have fun with it they're natural they
just watch and imitate they don't doubt
themselves they just go for it they're
not resisting it
and yet the adults are the adults doubt
themselves they resist it they're trying
to fit it in with what they were doing
before they don't really accept
uh the way they're being taught to do
things
there is they don't they just don't let
themselves go
the way the kids do and i think that's
largely why kids learn languages better
than most adults again assuming that
they want that they're interested i mean
no one's going to learn if they're not
interested adult or child
uh and you know very often there is
discussion this discussion amongst
teachers you know
um
adults learn differently from children
the second or third language acquisition
is not the same as the first language
well to some extent of course this is
true if we're learning a second language
we already have a first language
uh in our system which a
provides a sort of a a filter
creates resistance to the second
language because we're kind of used to
the first language
and so we have to overcome that
resistance and second of all on the plus
side we have a lot of vocabulary in that
first language which can help us in the
second language as i said so the
circumstances are not the same
but i think the basic learning process
insofar as the brain is concerned is the
same and i heartily recommend that you
read this book by manfred spitzer that i
have referred to before
which is called learning and the brain
and i'll put a link here on
my youtube
comments section
uh but the brain needs the stimulus it
needs some models it needs a lot of
input and the brain will gradually start
to
put labels on things and create little
patterns so that it can deal with all of
this and that's basically the same so
kids do any have an easier time with
language because they're not
as hung up about hanging on to that
first language they're more prepared to
just let themselves go there they hear
something they they want to communicate
with with their peers and and they just
pick up on it they allow the brain to
just pick up on it whereas adults want
to formalize the process they want some
rules
uh
some people are into you know passing
tests
uh
they get frustrated when they don't
remember the rules or if they get a low
mark on the test kids are not into that
the kids are just oh okay that's how
they say it and gradually imitating it
so
i think that
as an adult language learner
the best thing we can do is to simplify
the process
and try to learn like kids without
doubting ourselves without feeling
frustrated just enjoying the fact that
we're
able to communicate or that we're able
to understand and exposing ourselves to
more and more
uh of the language more and more content
that we're interested in and essentially
that's what i'm doing with check i'm
reading stuff that i'm interested in i'm
listening to stuff that i'm interested
in i can't speak very well it doesn't
bother me i'm not going to write a test
i'm not going to write the european
framework i couldn't care less whether
i'm at a1 a2 b1 b2 to me that's all
meaningless as i've said we had a
discussion at our forum at lincoln on
language testing and so forth and so on
and i said i
aside from chinese where i had to write
a test for the government you know i've
never taken a test in any of these
languages and i have no interest in
doing so
i do what i enjoy doing with the
language if it's if it's reading it's
reading if it's
speaking and speaking and to the extent
that i can speak i'm happy
uh
i'm just enjoying it and just like these
kids playing golf they're just enjoying
the golf i mean yeah they are that they
would like to do well uh and but because
they're enjoying it they end up doing
well
uh whereas if you're doubting yourself
and not
you know happy and uh frustrated and
worried about your test marks and so
forth uh you want to as well in my view
so
uh i think that uh best advice for a
language learner is to uh try to learn
like kids enjoy it just let it let it
all hang out let it go in and let it
come out and don't worry about it
just like the kids
so thank you for listening bye for now